explíquenos cómo entender que el
gobierno de venezuela y la oposición
están conversando para decidir si
reanudar o no las negociaciones que
tanta intención tienen realmente de
volverse a sentar
graciasmaria clara
fíjate yo creo que es un paso importante
el hecho de que se haya expuesto
públicamente
la reanudación de convertí diálogos en
función del objetivo de establecer
negociación sin embargo detrás de esto
en venezuela está desarrollándose todo
un debate en función de la legitimidad
del espacio hay sectores que lo
cuestionan hay sectores que desde la
oposición cuestionan la
representatividad de la plataforma
unitaria y su amplitud pero más allá de
eso lo que sí es claro y necesario en
venezuela es que pueda abrirse este
espacio así como también otros espacios
de diálogo en venezuela no solamente
entre el sector de el gobierno y la
oposición sino dentro de la misma
oposición que representa dificultades
para tener una sólida articulación en
función de avanzar hacia un proceso de
negociación certero y volvamos a hablar
de estos diálogos centrales porque lo
que quebró las conversaciones fue la
extradición a eeuu del empresario alexa
up que es a nicolás maduro ahora
venezuela insiste en que él debe estar
en su delegación tenemos porque importa
tanto saab en las negociaciones
diferente la secuencia de los últimos
hechos implica primero que aparezca en
la fotografía con un tuit simultáneo en
la misma hora en el mismo minuto tanto
jorge rodríguez representante de maduro
como gerardo bleu y representante de un
sector de la oposición esto implica
entre otras cosas una clara voluntad de
articulación y sin realización por lo
menos a nivel público unos minutos
después de jorge rodríguez representante
de maduro hace énfasis en la exigencia
de la incorporación de alexa en el
proceso de negociación pero es muy claro
que ésta es este es un mensaje hacia un
sector del chavismo que necesita ver
algún tipo de coherencia en mi discurso
dentro del gobierno de maduro pero el
hecho concreto y real es que han
expresado la voluntad de restablecer el
diálogo que están avanzando sobre pero
que es importante
observar un poco los argumentos y la
fachada que puede estar en el gobierno
de maduro más allá del objetivo concreto
que es avanzar en la eliminación de las
sanciones y en la posibilidad de que el
gobierno de los eeuu
influye positivamente en el tema de
avanzar sobre tendía los diez caminos a
propósito del papel de eeuu el
presidente de méxico respaldo a caracas
al decir que no iría a la cumbre de las
américas si washington no cambiaba su
decisión de no invitar al gobierno
venezolano y luego varios mandatarios
siguieron los pasos de lópez obrador
ahora eeuu suaviza algunas de las
sanciones contra cuba y venezuela se
puede entender esto como un intento por
mejorar la diplomacia de cara a la
cumbre
no creo que sea un problema de cara a la
cumbre aún a pesar de que puede traer
algunas consecuencias en este sentido el
objetivo fundamental de la posición de
los eeuu es a partir del principio
fundamental de que los países no tienen
amigos tienen interés en eeuu tiene
poderosos intereses en el tema petrolero
venezolano y que aún a pesar de que ha
sido un gobierno que hay ha pretendido
colaborar en el desarrollo de la
democracia y la posibilidad de
restablecimiento del estado de derecho
en venezuela sin embargo más sopesa en
este momento en el contexto
internacional el conflicto de la
invasión de
rusia sobre ucrania y las dificultades
que se están generando como consecuencia
tanto del acceso a combustibles
especialmente proyectándose a un mediano
plazo